[Musica]
buonasera
conoscete la favola del semaforo di
gianni rodari
parla di un semaforo che a un certo
punto della sua vita si stufa di
emettere luci verdi gialle rosse perché
vuole emettere solo luci blu ora
immaginate il caos generato dalla sua
scelta
appunto
dopo il caos generale generato nella
nella piazza il semaforo viene spento
perché non ha fatto il suo dovere in
quanto doveva occuparsi del traffico
cittadino
gianni rodari descrive semaforo come un
creativo non capito
cito proprio la favola e cosa dice il
semaforo alla fine poveretti io avevo
dato il segnale via libera per il cielo
se mi avessero capito ora sto tutti
saprebbero volare ma forse gli è mancato
il coraggio che peccato non aver capito
il semaforo è una favola un po amara che
sottolinea la creatività del semaforo
affossata da logiche di utilità ma
perché il semaforo non era libero di
fare quello che voleva di emettere una
luce blu la libertà assoluta non esiste
questa frase l'ha detta una delle donne
che stimo di più al mondo che è liliana
segre
in apertura il mix festival di milano di
quest'anno
io sono d'accordo con lei d'accordissimo
ma
parecchie volte nella mia vita mi sono
sentita come il semaforo
ecco
che cosa ho imparato dopo anni in cui mi
è stato detto segui le regole fai la
brava bambina ma anche si creativa però
forse non verrai capita quando sono
diventata designer ho imparato che
esiste una terza via una via che
abbraccia la creatività per creare cose
nuove e utili per la società
questa terza via è percorribile ora è il
mio lavoro ma per percorrerla bisogna
disimparare
ma per imparare che cosa
imparare che non esiste un solo punto di
vista da cui guardare le situazioni e
problemi
non bisogna mai lavorare da soli
e soprattutto tutti possono essere
creativi basso a darci delle occasioni
per esserlo
questa terza via non ve lo dico io che
esiste esiste veramente altrimenti non
esisterebbero le rotonde
leggo la citazione da wikipedia una
rotonda è un tipo di intersezione a raso
fra due o più strade
assolve alla funzione di moderazione
snellimento del traffico praticamente fa
quello che faceva il semaforo ma con
altre regole tutte sue
ogni giorno nel mio lavoro con le
aziende che seguo o davanti delle
persone che non si sentono per niente
creativi
guardano solo al semaforo cercano di
innovare semaforo e basta e soprattutto
provano a farcela da soli
ecco
torniamo al semaforo quello tradizionale
quello che conosciamo tutti
se provate a innovare a fare qualcosa di
diverso
riprogettando il semaforo fareste un
grave errore perché se guardaste al
problema quindi il traffico e non al
semaforo vi concederete molte più
possibilità molte più soluzioni
una l'abbiamo già citata la rotonda ma
perché no un bike sharing
una gestione a targhe alterne
insomma vedete quante idee vengono in
mente se non guardo più alla soluzione
in essere ma guardo al problema a monte
bene ora la vera sfida è sviluppare la
creatività
noi tutti abbiamo alle spalle una vita
scolastica per cui per prendere 10
dobbiamo dare delle risposte corrette
quindi scoperta dell'america
il presidente della repubblica sergio
mattarella
insomma abbiamo imparato in anni di
scuola che ha una risposta a una domanda
corrisponde una e una sola risposta
corretta
peccato che per problemi progettuali
complessi in cui sottende della
creatività non funzioni così ma anzi
dobbiamo cercare molte più soluzioni e
non solo come dicevo prima dobbiamo
concentrarci anche sulla domanda da
porci per esempio
vi do vi lancio una sfida come possiamo
riprogettare semaforo
questa sfida è molto limitante
se invece vi pongo la domanda come
possiamo migliorare il traffico
cittadino questa è una domanda molto più
interessante perché un po più ampia ecco
io la faccio facile in realtà ci vuole
veramente tanta fatica a disimparare a
rimettersi in gioco dopo anni e anni di
hai detto in una risposta sbagliata anni
anni di un punto di vista unico che
abbiamo dovuto abbracciare
un altro errore che si fa è quello di
pensare da soli
chi fa da sé fa per tre
se lo si dice evidentemente è vero in
molti casi ma non è vero nel mio lavoro
quando si vuole fare innovazione infatti
il massimo che possiamo fare è quello di
radunare delle competenze molto diverse
fra loro dargli una sfida quindi un
problema da risolvere è creare una buona
atmosfera
ma come si fa a far lavorare persone
molto diverse e attrarre tutti i loro
spunti e tirarli fuori la creatività si
può una delle tecniche più popolari di
gestione della creatività si chiama
brainstorming e consiste nel non dire
mai di no non giudicare mai le proprie
idee tutto quello che ci passa per la
testa dobbiamo dirlo ad alta voce al
massimo possiamo costruire sulle idee
degli altri con la formula si è come vi
dicevo sono vietati i no
ecco non tutti sanno che però esistono
diverse tecniche di generazione di idee
quindi diversi tipi di brainstorming
davanti a ad esempio gruppi di lavoro
che non si conoscono quindi la relazione
non è un reato oppure
ci sono dei timidi nel gruppo di lavoro
o al contrario dei caratteri
preponderanti io uso sempre un'altra
tecnica che è la mia preferita e si
chiama brain writing e consiste in
questo c'è un primo momento il silenzio
in cui tutte scrivono ciò che passa loro
per la testa sud i postit
tutti i posti poi vengono messe a
disposizione del gruppo letti a voce
alta e ciascuno
cresce e quindi sviluppa nuove idee
sulle idee degli altri
e molto bello perché tutti anche i più
timidi grazie a quella fase iniziale in
silenzio contribuiscono quindi è la
rivincita dei tim healy quindi non
poteva che essere il mio preferito
bene un'altra un altro errore che
facciamo è quello di pensare di non
essere creativi
toglietevi dalla testa che per essere
creativi bisogna saper disegnare
carta i pennarelli sono strumenti da
bambini
no affatto
sono strumenti molto utili in una fase
che si chiama prototipazione rapida
infatti le nostre parole sono molto più
interpretabili di artefatti tangibili ed
è visivamente
schizzate abbozzate su su carta e vi
assicuro che si salva un sacco di tempo
in riunioni interminabili
già per questo dovrete utilizzare la
prototipazione rapida
ecco anche qui l'ho fatta forse un po
semplice no in verità lo ammetto
lavorare in gruppo non è facile eppure
se ci pensate quando eravamo bambini nel
gioco ci davamo delle regole
un obiettivo e insieme lavoravamo per
raggiungerlo
eppure questa visione corale non viene
più stimolata a scuola la dobbiamo
imparare a 25 anni
con fatica quindi da adulti chiamandola
soft skill quando in verità di soft non
ha niente perché saper collaborare è
un'arma potentissima
quindi caro amato gianni rodari
il creativo non solo non è un emarginato
ma è utile e funzionale ed è
fondamentale per la società e per le
persone
sono d'accordo con liliana segre non
siamo liberi al cento per cento di fare
quello che vogliamo ma lei sarebbe
davvero offrirà di noi se riuscissimo a
aprire un po le nostre vedute e creare
qualcosa di veramente nuovo con nuove
regole altrettanto utili utili alla
società
beh
ora via libera sapete tutti volare
[Applauso]